Goodfellas is one of those movies that
whenever it comes on television
there goes my next few hours I'm
absolutely gonna watch that and that's
what's so powerful about that movie in
particular and and Marty's work for that
for that matter there's something about
the way he connects you as an audience
member and envelops you completely into
another world that you become entranced
by it and the rest of the world
dissolves away and that's the magic of
really making movies a lot of his films
and especially with Good Fellas
definitely deal in the Underworld and
that's been a recurring theme in a lot
of his work and I think people are
attracted to that but more so the fact
that he's always
trying to grasp the humanity of these
people the flawed nature of these
characters